yeah welcome to this blitz game I just
saw that I'm I have the sound switched
off I saw Sir Robert I heard so let's
have some sound these those clicks
they're helpful playing against
Grandmaster here from I think this is
turkey 92 we had the BOGO Indian the
opening that I'm doing a book about and
I think it was c5 I don't really yeah I
I didn't get come to to this part of the
post repertoire so this is not something
that I worked on yet only know the basic
ideas okay yeah he's trying to play
before the question is should I prevent
it or not you know let's let's just
ignore that and set up on ahead shock
you can almost always do that in this
kind of formation
yeah 95 might be a an idea but not at
the moment
okay so we've got an Hedgehog I tried to
get the Queen to a8 always like that and
it seems like a good setup
what doesn't have so many concrete ideas
to improve his position he doesn't have
any natural pawn rags c5 is very tough
to play not sure what this is about
maybe three maybe he wants to get it to
eat you it wasn't well placed on c2
early but that's true
so he covered you form he might be
intending to play F Freud ePHI offices
possibility let's get the rook opposite
the Queen if I that the moment is not
threatened I can take a couple of times
and then he fibers hanging so I don't
fear this at the moment takes takes
Bishop g2 Queen takes context context
9500 side extra porn
don't think if I was playable on the
other hand I'm threatening to play is 65
myself with an excellent position so he
needed to to retreat him in order to not
get get a kick with the fire from the
night so he 5 he might be able to play
you 5
I don't know that's I try some
aggressive idea maybe it is not not
valid but wanted to play b5 now maybe
maybe I can wait wait a little bit it's
a bit tight anyway with his pieces and I
don't see how he prevents b5 in the long
run anyway yeah this way
I should've thought I should have
thought about this a bit longer simply
overlook that his honoured and defiled
with the night
ah this wasn't necessary at all
yeah thought ahead d5
don't g4 hang I know I'm not sure he's
got 95 probably
I need to take this
really okay
our d5 look cool Calvin now it should be
some counterplay
so you force my idea I'm okay let's
let's just continue with this quickly so
Bishop c5 is coming
I give check here let's give the check
here then take on d5 so so I had still
he's got a seven object yeah what a
shame
that's really a shame
yeah nah I take him his even covering
this
the I bishops e6 has got 97 yeah there's
no luck in chess but sometimes there is
yeah all right you to resign that this
was a useless loss I'm pretty sure that
like it's in really good shape here I've
got everything set up how it is supposed
to be and G fries this is just weakening
what this is mistimed I need to prepare
this better
maybe a 6b fire even this wasn't
entirely clear at one point that was
certainly better again maybe not yeah it
just it works out I mean this 97 is just
just a problem and Bishop b5 flight
before it covers 86 so I know somewhere
we form right here it really looks looks
okay I don't know got b5 maybe a 6 b5
I've got really good pressure against
your form
yeah difficult game yeah thanks for
watching